Hey what is that what is good how you
live and how you feeling it is left go
it is Sims yo yo back on Monday after a
nice weekend what up I had jury duty you
went to salt Bay's restaurant man it was
packed yeah yeah that's great
are you done jury duty I I've gotten
lucky the last few times where I've
gotten cancelled out of it like like
I've told you where I had a call the
night before and they said you were not
needed oh wow but then I I have to go
here soon because I missed a time my
wife didn't open the mail and her busy
life dude I don't have to go online and
register or something Oh
I'm just letting you know as soon as you
do that yeah they're gonna send you one
well yeah I've already been sent it
though yeah I have to do it or I'm going
to jail in the next two weeks like
that's what they that's the letter I've
gotten last time if you go to jail yes
can you use your one phone call to be on
the podcast yes I appreciate it
the other thing that happened while I'm
at jury duty I'm watching our Martellus
Bennett video blow up it's crazy Simmons
did you know that 89% of the smokes
marijuana the funny thing about it right
is it was so arbitrary it was such an
arbitrary number like he made up a
number but I I what I've realized in the
media is it was so random that it looked
official is that what he said 89% he
said 89-year like yeah in the eighties
but he was like like 89 he just like
made it and it blew up I didn't really
make every word I saw I mean people send
me screenshots like I didn't really
listen to what anybody's had to say
about any of these subjects so I don't
least even a like went on a rant about
like he just didn't listen to anything
that's the thing is it's a statement
that you can rant off right out hearing
the full context and our in our context
was that okay so if I said 80% it didn't
mean all 80% were going home and rolling
big fatties every night my point was
that 80% a league does let's say 40%
smoke on a consistent basis and then let
other 40 percents like once a month or
something like that and I didn't mean
everybody was a pothead I was just more
taken aback it blew up Washington Post
all that it is crazy but no I mean
everything's crazy this day and age okay
so what's going on right I'm tired and
we started
damn podcasts a half-hour late you your
urine makeup when the show's supposed to
be starting it's not true so that's the
crap um and then you're doing origami
over here because that's what we do you
don't want to host shows anymore we're
gonna oh yeah I wanna pick it out so
we're you don't have a host we're having
an open conversation Oh and that what I
like to show people now can we show Sims
on the two-shot you see that smile on
his face
yep it's how we loosen them that's how
he doing just ask what about me is
pissing you off okay so James Harrison I
just want to do this your face is
missing yeah I know here's a cough or a
cold I was battling this weekend was it
allergies over I think allergies are
around yeah on Sunday right Mimi yeah
James Harrison retires and I thought
manage this guy a Hall of Famer and I
don't know I'm gonna go to you the
Oracle yeah five-time Pro Bowler
two-time All Pro right 2-time Super Bowl
champ right Defensive Player of the Year
right eighty four and a half career
sacks yeah and then he had the 100 yard
touchdown in the Super Bowl so he has a
defining moment yes is James Harrison a
Hall of Famer in your mind I mean let's
talk let's talk it out I don't think so
I don't think so I mean he's really good
another like guy that we always say like
NFL legend but not a hall-of-famer so
what's interesting is his first four
years the NFL right he started eight
games yeah and then after that went to
five straight Pro Bowls right so he has
this career which he's a bust he's a
bust he's a bust he's a bust
boom breakout yeah I don't know if he's
a hall-of-famer
you're better at context in history that
I am in terms of him playing that
position yeah I don't think the numbers
are gonna verify that enough nor do I
think listen he's a really good player
you know 2008 that season here yeah he
was playing defensive player of the year
I mean we played against them that year
when I was on the Tennessee Titans week
15 was a game for the number one seed in
the AFC playoffs right the Tennessee
Titans won if you remember that's where
like LenDale White stumped on the
Terrible Towel before the game and all
that but I could tell you this this is
where always the media voting drives me
crazy to a degree because as we're
preparing that game obviously we're
watching a ton of film and Pittsburgh
defense
Dick LeBeau and all the things they did
at that time it's hard to get prepared
for it so me and Carrie Collins we
watched the ton and I mean there's no
doubt James Harrison was really good but
he definitely wasn't the best player on
his defense but he wasn't the best
defensive player award on the NFL
Polamalu ba ba ba Lu was like hands I
mean it was out of this world that year
that was the best year Polamalu ever had
in his career I thought and it was
Sandra that he got someone else he got
someone else the either yes yeah I think
I think James Harrison and my mind goes
down in the Hall of Fame character yeah
the NFL right I think the last few years
the caricature of James Harrison smoke
and chains wrapped around his neck and
wearing sweat suits and being the bench
press like I think that he could have a
very good post NFL career and I
definitely not a broadcaster but like a
personality yeah cuz like he's a
caricature yourself he is a caricature I
could see him going a few ways to I
think he's obsessed enough with training
and things like that a coach I know
strength something like that or he opens
up training facilities for young kids or
whatever it may be talked about crazy
characters or strengths code they are he
see he fits that mold of that kind of
like meathead guy like look at me I'm
doing 225 on the incline and I'm writing
this down right it was a left go work
out with James Harrison oh that would be
a magnificient that would be amazing
gosh okay I mean some of the ways he
lifts that would be he would look at me
and just he would not even want to talk
to me like I feel like we walked in to
be like all right let's do this he'd
look at you he'd look at me and go
alright Chris here's what we're gonna do
crap the other thing that was happening
a lot is I feel like we came to an end
of bear vs. lion I think we've reached
an end but the our listeners have not
we're on the Siberian tiger I already
start we looked at some videos of the
house I've scouted it out me and
Charlotte or I need you to scout
something different right what I've
realized is last time might've been a
little unfair I came prepared yeah did
not right we got a ton of possible
mascot battles across the NFL okay from
Giants against jets to Buccaneers versus
Raiders here's how we're gonna do this
every Monday we will
a new battle okay and then on Wednesday
we will argue our battle okay either
your dad right I'll Simms right or
whoever our guest is this Wednesday it's
going to be Peter King's food in for
Peter King yeah but Peter King will
watch the battle that we have between
this and we are going you pick these
back you're just picking battles that
people comment and that's a minute or so
here is the first pull of the day you
have to let me get some audio real quick
man it was disappointing I'm
disappointed reach in there then my lion
lost still don't believe it go for it
all right I got you
and our first battle is Duncan Simmons
says Paul Brown versus often so shout
out to Duncan Simmons yes whose man we
have Falcons vs. Eagles and he picked
Paul Brown versus a dolphin so the
Browns are named after Paul Brown and
the Miami Dolphins right this is gonna
be a great battle it is I mean if this
now we get to pick we have to figure out
who gets what so I'm gonna let you have
the first pick of the draft do you want
Paul Brown to the dolphin I'm coming to
dolphin nice all right so on what are we
really going on like what is the brown
this isn't gonna say it's a no it's pulp
it's a person yes and wherever you
making this fight happen in the water or
on land yeah it's a little problem there
I was more taking it like the brown
paper bag and as I say that brown paper
bag could be a problem for the dolphin
he chews on that and chokes he's dead
you're giving away a lot now I have some
strategy against right but no you're
talking about an old white man who can't
swim we're in trouble you're in trouble
possibly one Wednesday we will argue
Paul Brown versus dolphin your dolphin I
will be Paul Brown Peters I kind of want
to do like right away too Peter
yeah so he hasn't started off right
Peter serious question let's get our
sound effects ready to quick in their
prime from Isaac diamond Calvin Johnson
versus Jerry Rice
Wow I don't usually put all them in but
this was a good one this is a good one
gosh in their prime yes
gosh I think I'm taking Calvin Johnson I
am too in their prime constantly call
Jerry Rice the greatest and then
constantly put people like Randy Moss
Calvin Johnson and Tia over because it's
like consistent greatness what he had
but I don't think his ceiling was ever
the same as tea Oh Randy aura Calvin
Johnson in their prime Calvin Johnson or
Randy Moss oh I would go with Randy okay
I do think Randy could do more with the
short pass and make something happen
after the catch but in terms of the ball
in the air oh my gosh I mean if I've
ever seen anything like confidence yes
it is special but yeah Calvin Johnson I
mean again I told you I mean I've know I
told the story at some point and one of
our 9,000 podcasts but the fact we flew
to Georgia Tech the year after I lost my
spleen because we had the top five pick
and they want me to throw to Calvin
Johnson at the pro others workout he's
never told me this oh I never told you
this so we flew in a private plane me
and Gurdon and Bruce Allen and we're
gonna go work out Calvin Johnson and we
don't want anybody to know so we're
going up there and Troy Aikman and
Michael Irvin and I mean I'm forget I'm
excited to see Calvin Johnson I'm
[ __ ] nervous cuz I'm not right and
I'm going damn this is the first time
they're gonna see me and I can't [ __ ]
throw in Calvin Johnson your spleen
right and Calvin Johnson's gonna go damn
I don't want to play for this team he
sucks and I sucked I mean I suck what
does that mean I got him that I probably
even inflated his value to the team with
all the great catches he had to make
during our work and we're legitimately
throwing who I was throwing like ducks
and Quackers and like I was just trying
to complete it how does anyone say
anything to you I'm sure that was one of
the first times to go wait what the [ __ ]
happened to our quarterback sorry for
the swear and son you were throwing it
all over the poem skinny posts and I'm
going oh my gosh and he's reaching back
with one hand and just snagging it how
good maybe oh he was he was I mean again
when we talk about catch radius I think
that was the first time in my mind they
went oh my gosh this is what people are
talking about like
with catch radius people like I could
throw the ball ten feet off target and
even I was like I'm one for one wow this
is amazing yeah it was special had you
ever thrown to anybody like that a
little bit like Roy Williams when I was
coming out of Texas it was a lot like
that Roy wasn't as big as Calvin Calvin
it expands yeah closed closed Roy ran
for 37 coming out just like Calvin did I
forget cuz I remember so many of the
older boys when he got too big he
couldn't run the same yeah but but
Calvin was a giant man I mean that's why
Calvin's knee gave out but you can't be
that big and cut that awesome and think
oh my knee will last forever
yeah he was I think we're gonna look
back and realize that like say Kwan and
Calvin and we should make a team of all
those guys I don't know what the name of
that team would be how the Avengers
you're right Cam Newton at quarterback
right like if they just walked off you'd
be like it's like Space Jam yeah like
none of those guys make sense yes
like who created Calvin Johnson I don't
know I don't know all right still mom
and his dad which goes back to the
health conversation yes it does all
right so I have four main topics each
have subtopics right the four topics
that Sims will be choosing in the out of
left go field hat are the quarterback
whispers Oh
show me the money you show it to me
literally I need some money
uh-oh bad off seem so bad offseason and
as the Patriots world turns
Oh as the world turns all right so why
don't you reach in there and tell us
what is the first topic for Sims and let
go as the Patriots world turn of course
it does
all right so the two I've picked you
have not there's like though the ones
you didn't want me to pick huh
well no Paul Brown versus dolphins
hilarious right okay so now which
Patriots I'm a little dolphin to drown
that white man drown them all right and
the first one is there's no way Paul
Brown can fight a dolphin I don't think
I'm land land I'm still taking the
dolphin okay so he's gonna whoop his
butt before he runs out of air and then
he'll wiggle his way back in the water
here ruining a lot of your arguments
Amendola questions a Belichick yes
did so I go on to nfl.com and I see a
story about man it's hard to play for
Belichick he's kind of an a-hole yes and
that was the headline and then I read
the article and I was like you guys
buried the lede Amendola talked about
Malcom Butler and he said I hate my I
have my thoughts about it because I was
out there putting my blood sweat and
tears out in the field that night and
one of our best players wasn't on the
field to tell you the truth I don't know
why I did ask but I didn't get any
answers he's going to play more football
in his career and he's going to be a
great player for a long time with that
said I don't know how the business
aspect went into that decision I don't
know the personal aspect between him and
bill but as a friend
I would have loved to seen him on the
field that day few things one he asked
and didn't get answered right anand dole
was probably not the only guy that asked
generally not apparently it's the talk
of the locker room if he's willing to
say that those are the type of things
left code that if it happens during the
game the tom brady was walking around
the side he's going why is it Malcolm
out there why isn't that somebody was it
like me and the fact that Amendola
called him a friend and said he's going
to have a great rest of the career how
much of the Malcolm Butler situation
caused these guys to go to other teams
and Grunk to still be mulling retirement
what do you think the butler thing may
have set all of this off I think that
it's just gave him them had given some
of these guys a jumping off point to
spout off on a guy that they've kind of
wanted to spout off on a little bit and
Belichick and now they have a little bit
of a leeway to go somewhere here I mean
just reading between the lines it
doesn't scene Tom Brady liking the tweet
of memos all those kind of things to me
it sounds like the players for whatever
he got in trouble for don't think it was
that big of a deal and then bill was
trying to prove some you know overall
point will we ever know you we will
because I'm gonna find out I'm gonna
find out no too many people in New
England
whether you like it or not bill and
bearish I know him haha I have never
been more nervous after you've said I
know what I mean bearish belch
ex-assistant bears that they don't like
me in New England it's official I know
that what do you mean they don't like me
I can tell I mean bill who doesn't want
to look at me or shake my
and Baird who does he really look at no
I know some but them bears I saw his
bears his assistant at the hunters
meeting he walked right by me I
literally had to go hey how you doing
and then like make him I had to make him
turn around and say hello to me man
but I just I think it's more and more
fascinating all of these guys who have
never come out before ya talking about
something so openly yes it's also
awesome because as an Eagles fan I feel
like I caused all of this yeah he wears
on people it's a tough experience up
there I mean whether it's been coaches
or office people whoever it is they
leave they're going damn I made it out
alive I might be smarter I was it's
absolutely miserable why I was working
there yes we won but I was absolutely
miserable on a daily basis that's how
most of them are I saw an advertisement
for the Marine Corps right and it was
like you leave here a better man and I
was like I don't know if I can handle
the process of becoming a better man
that's why I feel like Belichick is like
joining the Marines you leave and people
go wow you're a you're a tough son of a
gun yeah but going through it I don't
know if I'd you wouldn't go back no but
not go back I mean that's the reason I
got out my coach friends always tell me
they go well you did start off at the
worst place and I'm like yep I did
you're right but it's also the best
place it was the best place - all right
let's go to the next Patriots topic next
question has the Patriots world turns
Grunk not at stardom offseason program
and this is where it continues again
Grunk not at the program Jeff how of the
athletic reported that the absence from
voluntary workouts is quote about the
money
Grunk twenty eight is to eight million
dollars in 2018 per spot track however
there are no guarantees left on that
six-year fifty four million dollar deal
he signed in June 2012 right so I'm
looking at it right now I'm going wow
one you don't see many contracts go to
completion in the NFL
either you're renegotiating or they're
cutting you before you get to that money
yeah but we're at the point where
there's no guaranteed money line yes so
Grunk is would in essence be playing
this year and if he got hurt he could
lose a lot of money right well once he
gets the seat yes I mean what he got
hurt to start the year he's gonna get
his nine million and he's supposed to
get this year his average whatever it
may be now is he below like I got spot
track up here right now he's the fourth
highest paid tight end in a football
right now being in your lis average
salary right Jimmy Graham's now number
one at 10 million Travis Kelce Stu would
nine point three million
Jordan reads just a hair under that and
also at nine point three million and
then Gronkowski's averaging nine yeah we
know that where I'm gonna cuz he's
better than all of those guys so he does
deserve to be paid more right now they
got him for the low the Patriots are
smart I did if I was there or they were
talking about Moshe gate his contract
right after I left and they got him in
six years ago 2012 right yes I was there
so do you think bill will repay him well
I think bill will give him a contract or
do you think he's gonna say play it up
well last year didn't they Sweden his
deal and give him an extra five million
dollars if he reached some of the
incentives right so he made that but hey
listen maybe it is about money it might
be certainly I also just think it's day
one of OTAs and nobody wants to be or
not even its training it's not even OTAs
it's just training like yeah Grunk he's
obviously getting trained by T b12 and
that method so maybe he's got his own
workout going on already okay because
people are saying that if he misses
three practices he loses out only
250,000 dollars that's not the workout
bonus right right yes so it depends it
he's usually like like contracts that
have like ninety percent
you know participation rates offseason
workouts are 95% so if it's 90 percent
and let's yeah you're right I mean it's
gonna be three or four maybe he can miss
so where is the Chris Sims brain leaning
right now does grunt get more money does
Gronk retire does Gronk play under his
current contract does all this end I
think Gronk gets more money I think they
find a way to finagle another gear to
his worth of money I don't or find a way
to maybe give him something more
guaranteed this year cuz to me because
he's threatening retired right you're
not offering him a long-term deal no a
three year extension now he's a
guaranteed money that he wants this year
right and infer for him you gotta say
like yeah if you're contemplating
retirement right you can't do that and
say oh I want three more years because
if you retire a year or two early
they're gonna go how about some of that
signing bonus back a la Richie incognito
right now which we should probably talk
about a little bit too because he
doesn't apparently seem to know what his
contract situation is oh is that what
happened he said I'm retiring they're
like well then pass back I mean they
made him take a pay cut he agreed to the
pay cut he pissed off then he says he's
retiring
then he think he realizes oh I might
have to pay back 1.5 million dollars in
my signing bonus and he tweets at the
team hey just release me please so I
don't have to be here so I'm very
interested to see where that goes G
Incognito's not thinking something
through no but Gronk I look at it and
it's interesting this whole retirement
storyline with the WWE balichek isn't
gonna lose in this game of chicken bowel
checks not gonna be like oh no if I
don't pay you more speaking of Belichick
let's get to the last one what's crazy
though how we talked about Gronkowski
being the number for paid tight end in
football the number 10 paid tight end in
football is Dwayne Allen who's also on
that roster and he's making 7.3 million
dollars yeah like she was that an indie
contract that Patriots got in the trade
let me just say what the hell did they
do last year do they trade for Dwayne
Allen they did right we're know I don't
know because I know that the Dorsett
Jacobi Pro Set was a trade I don't know
I think Dwayne Allen may have just been
a sign I got it I just can't imagine him
paying that much money I'll go to the
balichek press conference I was in
married
duty and I watched 24 minutes of Bella
check talking which is in essence
watching a robot explained their
programming to people just a corrected
it was a Colts contract and he was
traded right
no I don't know great so Bella checking
the press-conference contract Colts
Colts won he talked about how it's easy
to rank positions but it's hard to
compare them he said it's easy to rank
the top 5 tight ends but it's hard to
compare the number 2 corner to the
number 3 running back and I was like
bill gets a weird sick satisfaction out
of that I could tell yeah you saw do you
mean like him going into a room and not
letting anybody in there and then here
in the garage door go open that this is
the time of the year I would say around
11 o'clock every morning bills walking
upstairs into the front office part of
the New England Patriots facility he's
walking into their draft room and then
about five seconds after you hear him in
the draft to hear
and that's the big metal garage door
they have guarding the draft board where
nobody else on the organization gets to
even see it other than him NICUs area
the owners and maybe pro personnel and
the draft board is mainly the big board
which is is that the compilation yes I
mean you have all positions ranked right
and then probably have an overall big
board to go to problems like you were
just said that's why you have to have
intricate grading systems right you
can't have like you got to go one guy's
a 7-point - and the other ones at 7.15
because you get you might get to the
draft process and go dan we got like
twelve 7.20 you know how do we
differentiate them through them so there
there has to be a little more detail
than just a normal roundabout number he
also said they use mock drafts to like
like quiz themselves and prepare for
things going on the trailer he said that
there's he said to scout a guy there's
it's like a hundred piece puzzle and and
he went on and started listing things he
said agility strength and then he goes
medical opinions and these were the ones
that I really found interesting ability
as a teammate rate of improvement rate
of decline
he mentioned injuries multiple times but
then I realized Bill probably does
everything like willingness to eat
dinner indoors instead of spending money
at a restaurant definitely and then he
talked about need versus talent and he
said well again the whole draft need
thing I don't really understand it you
put a card up on the board that doesn't
mean the guy is a good player I think
it's important to acquire good players
wherever they are if you take a position
a player at a position that you might
need but he's not good enough to fill
that need it's a wasted pick yes I don't
understand the whole need thing right so
we always talk about a blend between
draft in need and Belichick is saying I
don't need need yeah so what I would I
think like so like we're not cool I
always tell you about the sign that was
by my office right we're not collected
we're not just here collecting players
we're building a team and they laugh at
teams that go I got a first round great
on this guy or a second round or we're
gonna take the best player available
because they don't agree with that
they love their they laugh at that in
fact they like almost encouraged like Oh
they tell you that they have a 2nd grade
2nd round grade on the guy just go along
with it and say oh yes us too
don't tell them about our grading system
whatever it may be so that's the first
part of it now you know they do you
think do they collect all those
headlines and like remind on the draft
they keep everything like I told you I
mean we were looking under stones in
Germany and I was in valuating people
that I was like who the hell is this guy
von der van von schweetz
is who ran a for nine but whatever the
the need verse talent thing yeah okay
that has that's the proper way he
explained it right okay right I mean
you're not gonna just go oh a we need a
middle linebacker
this is extent Gosselin picks 31 of the
draft but oh this middle linebackers are
54th best player on the board you don't
just take him at thirty-one course right
so he's saying basically you have to
balance out need with valuable players
on the board to go along with this so
maybe the need might not match up with
the number one player that need or at
that position but they might have a
second position of need where they go oh
well d-tackle there's a guy here we're
picking 31 and we have him as 15th in
the draft so we can take him that so I
think that's what he was basically
saying he's not just gonna draft a guy
just cuz oh we need this position and
we're gonna do it yeah of course it just
it did seem like he found every other
team comical that it's how they draft so
like these last few months if you're the
Patriots building you're like looking
around at other teams in the league you
mean like what are these people talking
about well yeah I mean even during I
think it's more during the summer season
the NFL season when the scouts are out
on the road and then you come back and
you hear they give all their information
hey listen I talked to the strength
coach on this team and you know Johnny's
Johnny's in the weight room at the right
time every day and does some extra stuff
you know I talked to his guidance
counselor and who she said he's a little
all over the place with school I mean he
gets it done but it's not perfect so
they're gonna go all angles is of the
player and then they're also gonna go
yes you know on my travels to see this
player I was with scouts from blah blah
blah teams and they talked about this as
the player that of the player of what
made him to be so all that goes into it
certainly
yeah well if you were a scout I would
never talk to anybody in the Patriots
organization yeah no you got to be
careful all right let's go our next
topic we have three left quarterback
whisper uh-oh bad offseason it's show me
the money
quarterback whisper verse all right
quarterback whispers we have three
people this week Simms three people Sean
Payton Bruce Arians
and Ryan Leaf damn yeah they are there
whispers to Humber yellers all right and
which one are we talking about first we
are talking about Bruce Arians Bruce
cards should take Lamar Jackson amen to
that
so Bruce Arians came out there and said
that's one guy I'm really intrigued with
because he can spin it and he's been in
a pro style offense and he's been
coached hard by Bobby Petrino he sounds
like a young Chris Simms he brings that
unique skill set and it makes me look
back at Vince Young Vince could beat you
and he was a heck of a leader I don't
know why it didn't work out for him but
listening to him now telling his story
he's like I didn't put the time in I
think Lamar puts the time in he's going
to get better and he just brings that
unique ability to break the game open
with his legs yes I mean in a draft over
talking about there's not a lot of leap
like skilled players right especially in
the offensive side of the ball this
other than say Quan Barkley might be the
most dangerous offensive player in the
draft I mean so the again is it raw
they're things not to like but yeah I
mean basically what Bruce is trying to
say the Cardinals should take him at
would pick 12 is that where they're at
15 I make a lot of sense I mean it
really would again I am just a believer
and the fact that Lamar Jackson once he
gets outside of the college environment
and no more 20-hour rule and you have
coaches watching you on a daily basis
and they're getting there and oh you
know you're the coach and you're you're
there you are coach left go hey look at
Lamar your left foots here and your
right foot needs to be here day after
day after day and then it goes onto the
field and you go hey Lamar think about
your left foot and your shoulder turn or
whatever and you consistent all sudden
you start going damn okay [ __ ] you know
he's hit the bull's eye now right on 20
come back she's throwing he's spot on
every time because like Bruce said
they're too
seize it he can spin the ball is truly
the quarterback whisperer he's up there
every quarterback talks about how he
works with them whether it's Peyton
Manning or Ben Roethlisberger everyone
over the years now he's also had some
ones where he went
let me try and work on Logan Tom Wright
and he's he sees raw talent yeah that's
rising at the moment that's the would
see to me that's what you're supposed to
do you know again we worry about oh it's
the number one thing that you and I we
drives us crazy about the NFL I mean
oh let's drafting back up cuz he's good
in the meeting room he's good on the
read I mean Bruce is like no let me take
raw town let me take a raw talent and I
might make him a superstar he might be
Brett Favre or somebody like that that's
what he's looking at so how much does it
mean to you that Bruce Arians said that
to me it does it feel like a vote of
confidence
yeah it's just another be one that like
people I really trust in the NFL on the
subject to go well that's good that's
good he sees it the same way I do
it was interesting a group of NFL
executives voted the Cardinals most
likely to trade up for a quarterback
rule so if they trade up I doubt it
would be for Lamar right the sentiment
around the NFL seems to be you can wait
for Lamar it seems to be I mean right
exactly you can't wait and what if the
Chargers are hot on them or some other
team inside of them they might have to
be careful I mean Lamar Jax is the kind
of guy that I just feel like we're all
gonna watch preseason football and we're
gonna see him throw a bomb and we're
gonna see him run for a 70 yard
touchdown and every team in football is
gonna go damn why didn't we pick him yes
I mean I just feel like that's just what
it's waiting to be alright let's go to
the next government whisper Sean Peyton
talks ups and Arnold so this is Peter
King's mm QB article again Peter Kim
will be here on Wednesday Sean Payton
said he was talking about all the
quarterbacks he said I feel for all the
teams that feel they have to draft a
quarterback you can't just make one in
our league it's and I wouldn't feel
confident about this group having to
find my guy at the top yeah he said
quote I wouldn't be surprised if one of
these guys is left standing in four or
five years if only one of these guys
left standing in four or five years and
if so I guess it would be Sam
Darnell yeah now the Saints are a team
just like the Cardinals right but that
are rumored to take a quarterback by
but Shawn still the coach yeah what do
you read into this is the guy that you
respect with a quarterback that you're
not that high oh yeah I do and again
like Sam darlings a top 20 pick to me I
just don't think he's the number one or
number two pick I don't that's the way I
look at it I don't I'm not gonna sit
here and argue with it I mean you know
where I stand with the quarterbacks they
all have flaws I can see what people
like in Sam Donald I just don't think
it's gonna translate we'll see I mean I
just don't see superstardom I don't see
slam dunk number one or number two pick
that's what I would say I mean to me
he's a little bit of a project and he's
young and there's some things he can
improve on but I mean I know Shawn's not
the only guy I've talked in the NFL that
I respect about the quarterback position
whose watch Sam darlin been like I kind
of liked what I saw you know so I get it
what that's fine I don't see it it's not
that I don't think he can't be a good
player just I don't see that slam dunk 1
or 2 and he's right with like he put its
spot on I mean again none of these guys
are luck or Carson Wentz none of these
guys are as good as the three last year
like we've talked about yes I mean he
loved mahomes last year we know I mean I
know that the Saints had mahomes is the
number one player in the draft they were
gonna there was a reason the Chiefs
traded up to pick before the Saints to
get my home's because they had a pretty
good inkling that they were gonna go
Patrick mom's yeah I think mahomes on
the Saints would be great but Lattimore
worked out pretty well really well yeah
it's so funny the Saints had all these
draft things they were gonna do yeah
none of them happened no and now they're
sitting there with a great draft class
oh yeah the last one was Ryan Leaf on
busts yeah this one I find very
interesting so Ryan Leaf suggested that
of the five quarterbacks that are ranked
at the top of this class yep the
quarterback that reminds him the most of
himself in 98 as a possible bust was who
Sims I'm gonna guess it's Baker Mayfield
it is Baker made yeah quote a good
litmus test for me is always when I
listen to radio interviews or TV
interviews I tend to close my eyes and
listen to the voice and hear the answer
I always say if it sounds like the 98
version of Ryan Leaf there's a definite
red flag to be raised there now he did
come out last year and say the most
impressive of the incoming quarterbacks
was - Sean Watson right and he was right
there it doesn't mean
is completely valid yeah he also said
about a month ago on Fox Sports Radio
the highly competitive borderline
arrogant angry individual yeah the
biggest thing for me is how will he deal
with failure right that's where my
downfall was when things began to fall
apart how was I going to deal with it
when the media is on you you play a bad
game the whole city is on you that's
where we'll see where Baker Mayfield is
at right now there's no evidence to back
up that when things get tough he won't
break
first question yeah how much value do
you put on Ryan Leaf talking about this
topic I mean I because I listen to it is
funny right
we always hear quarterbacks that were
very successful try to talk about
players and which ones of them will also
be successful right this is the first
time I've ever heard of a guy openly
talk about being a bust and talking
about bust traits I've never heard it
from this side before the right and if
there is anyone that's more able to
locate problems and stuff it's probably
going to be Ryan Leaf sure not saying
that he's gonna be in a perfect
evaluator of talent to grow back
position but he definitely would notice
things before other people would notice
this yeah and it made me stop and go I
wanted to write it off yeah and be like
all Ryan Leaf is going for the the
attention grab and stuff but I don't
know if he is I think this is just an
honest evaluation to I don't think it's
an attention grabber at all I think he's
truly just given his honest talk here
about the quarterbacks on their
conversation listen Ryan Leaf had
big-time town he knows what Talent looks
like I'll say that so he's gonna he's
gonna have a good idea of that and then
yes I mean all the points he brought up
are certainly big questions I would just
push back with this you know Baker
Mayfield been through a lot he was at
Texas Tech they didn't want him they
didn't know how to offer him a
scholarship and they said you know we
still don't want even though you came
here and played good leave okay so then
he goes to Oklahoma here to prove
himself there so he's been through
trials and tribulations and the he loves
the sport I understand he's got a little
bit of that attitude everyone talks
about it being an amazing leader that's
the number one that's where I was gonna
go with this I mean it's not even
amazing leader but like as I've told you
some of the people I know around the NFL
literally said they've gone out of their
way to try to find something bad about
Baker Mayfield and they cannot find it
like everybody loves them the team loves
them the equipment guys love them the
coaches love them he's all in on
football you're heard John Elway and the
Broncos say how impressive he was at the
senior ball right so to me I understand
Ryan Leaf Ryan Leaf sorry I'm since they
Brian mallet at first
Ryan lease point and I think those are
good questions I will say this I agree
with them after one of the quarterbacks
were to bust
I would pick Baker Mayfield to be the
bus really I would yes because of the
size issue and he's not as athletic as I
think people think he is they're mine
right
I mean he's learned that in the against
Georgia yeah right I mean he couldn't
outrun many of those guys yeah and
really when you when you saw any games
like that even Ohio State he made a few
little plays in the pocket but he didn't
run anywhere you know for eight five
speed is not gonna run around the edge
in the NFL it's just not gonna happen
yeah it's interesting because I think
it's a very unfair thing that we do is
calling players bust we talked about
this right the GM overdrafts you right
but if this quarterback crop we are
gonna learn so much about he can be the
one to fall I think that's the one where
I look at like where we might be
scenaries because I hear him as if he's
there for the Jets or three or the
Broncos at five maybe the Broncos will
do it I'll say this as much as I like
him you know why like Baker Mayfield I
would have a hard time drafting them I
just in this purchasing you're not
seeing the elite traits and I'm saying
well you would have a hard time drafting
a six-foot quarterback if I'm gonna sit
here and just have honest talk with
everybody I would like honest yeah I
mean that's just the way I feel I mean
we we constantly go back to the two
quarterbacks in the history of the sport
in true stories and Wilson right and I
want to go OK but you know drew brees
beat Andy Roddick one-on-one on tennis
Russell Wilson just went and hit
homeruns for the Yankees like there's
special athletes so I don't know if he
is in that category with the sighs it's
just troubling I'm not he might be a
star I'm not saying that I'm just saying
if there's one that I had to pick as the
bus I would pick him interesting yeah
but yeah I it's I just thought would you
go who would you go bust
oh I think I think the easiest one is
Lamar yeah because I think that they're
structural
choose to his throwing motion by all of
the off the it's it's more of the I
don't there's just question management
the Lamar Jackson management right is
what we've got I don't I don't know all
that and then I would say the other one
is Josh Allen yeah just because I look
at his physical traits and I find him to
be huge and of a strong arm and be able
to run and do all those things but there
are so many question marks about his
performances in college yeah that a lot
of it is a projection right and a lot of
it is wait until he gets some really
good coaching and some better players
around them and I'm like well those are
the coaches from Carson Wentz and so I
just I have faith in them yeah I get you
this is this is why this is a great
draft because they all have fought and
that's why I think Josh Rosen's my
number one right because I have the
least amount of question I mean he's too
smart he's too prepared his structure is
too good like he you know he's got all
of that Who am I missing
Sam Darnell yeah I just don't think
since and Arnold is probably the number
one bust because I'm on with you I don't
think he's athletic enough for the NFL
to get away with what he didn't come
right right
but so I know they all got it's it's a
great combo this year and again I have
friends in the NFL oh I talked to they
have Rosen is the number one quarterback
they're evaluators are not the GM's
they're not making the call right but
they're people I talk to and there ain't
no Rosen was the guy for me I checked
the most boxes I thought he was the best
one yeah so I get it it's it's
interesting Rosen's the guy that I would
have the most confidence in but I
wouldn't bet on him to be like the
number one like if they all panned out
he's not number one he's he's got pure
physical ability to be that like get on
my team get on my shoulders team and
I'll carry you like that's not what he's
in yeah he's like the highest floor and
the second lowest ceiling in my mind
behind Arnold like Darnell has the
lowest ceiling lowest ceiling yeah I I'm
I think I'm with you there - that's
where I think the Josh Allen thing is
interesting too because I think Josh
Allen has the wood throws and he has the
highest floor like to me I tend to so
many people who disagree yeah I know
because out to me that I look at Allen
and go the very worst he's going to be
is like a really high end
like backup quarterback or like a
middle-of-the-road starting quarterback
with that size the best Wonderlic squirt
of the quarterbacks and his ability to
throw I just have a hard time going oh
it's gonna fall apart he's gonna be out
of the league in five years yeah I agree
you know it'll be interesting it will be
all right so two topics left Simms uh-oh
bad offseason and show me the jeez
what'd you do this weekend I died I
drank I ate a lot of chickens so that's
what you did you ate a lot of chicken
suit that's what gave you the coffee
Oh bad offseason Oh bad offseason it is
not you know who you're going right
there really yeah I don't all right well
then the first pull the first pull 400
bad offseason this week it is reuben
foster charged with DV
yes domestic violence this is
interesting one because it's a mix of
human like humanity
yeah and then also business yeah I'm
reading Peter Kings article they're
talking about how the Saints felt so
lucky that Rueben foster they didn't
take him and I'm sitting there going man
this Rueben Foster is accused and
charged of attacking his live-in
girlfriend leaving her bruised rupturing
her eardrum and then according to the
report dragged her by her hair threw her
out of the house and punched her in the
head eight to ten times
no one's lucky in this situation right
like that's the humanity of this is holy
crap this is still an issue of major
players in one league committing acts of
domestic violence
and I just a few days later to be like
man whoa man thank God we didn't draft
that guy I know I was like okay not the
best choice of words but that's not what
they meant of course of course
now the 49ers have not caught him a
49ers the photos the Niners Judy Niners
they have not caught him they are
waiting for the legal process to go out
which I understand as well yes
you know Darryl Worley got arrested and
he got immediately cut when you're a
first-round pick you get a longer leash
and they want to see the law play out
yes when you heard this though you were
like this is why you don't draft the guy
yeah I mean the
the things you heard in the NFL that
there was there's a lot this is why he
between the shoulder mastic violence no
heard there was a lot of things to be
scared there was off the field concerns
yes was around exactly right that along
with some people thought the structural
issue in his shoulder was a little scary
so that's why he fell and then the 49ers
of course traded back up to get into the
first round to take him at the end of
the first round for that but that that's
exactly why you see a lot of teams and
organizations just go we're not gonna
deal with it just know right and you
know he is a phenomenal football player
we know that I do Chi I think the 49ers
are handling it the right way I mean
come on let's let him have his you know
in court no doubt about that and Jed
York that's what I like about Jed Jed
seems like a very normal human being and
I know Kyle and John Lynch are too and
they're not gonna pass judgment before
they are and I also like that Jed York
said he's going to make the final call
you have to do that he's got to the
coach is going to favor the player
especially if he's talented like it's
hard to separate that right yes cuz
that's his guy I drafted him so and now
the Niners are at nine and probably if a
draft has reported that's where that's
where it becomes interesting too right
so do you mean what do you do with the
Niners there because you're sitting
there and also those are pointing to
Tremayne Edmunds or row kwan smith be in
there the right name position that ruben
foster politically and it's a huge need
now it is i mean we think you know if
you're the GM yes do you act like he's
off your team like i know that we're
waiting but in your mind are you going
he's not a part of our team i would i
would it is just everything I've read it
seems a little too serious yeah I
understand yeah if he committed this
you're off the team
what's staying sorry if you do waste
that pick on somebody like a Jermaine or
a row Kwan and then all the sudden he
comes back yes but you might miss out on
another position if Patrick Wilson
Navarro Bowman in Oliver yeah yeah I
mean you're right about that and this is
the Seattle scheme where they're looking
for a Bobby Wagner in a cage a right or
a you know our guys in Jacksonville and
miles Jack Intel in South and Smith
right
so it wouldn't be the worst thing in the
world I'm extremely interested to see
what my buddy Kyle does I really am
because I don't know what to say those
two linebackers that are there ro Quan
is a slightly lesser version of Ruben
Foster I wrote that in my petition yeah
and my notes I just wrote he's he's
Ruben Foster from last year but not
quite as good and then the tremaine
admins kids is one of my favorite cast
in the draft
I mean he's that's my favorite guy he is
an absolute freak yes he really is he's
amazing he certainly he's Anthony bar
with game tape yeah exactly
yes yeah you know we've actually seen
employment right exactly right it's not
rejection two more guys that are Oh bad
offseason not as serious as Ruben Foster
which I'm gonna say again it's
disgusting
it is okay Mark Sanchez Mark Sanchez
what the hell mark suspended for
performance-enhancing drugs for games
quote I have taken the same regimen of
supplements for the past five years
without any issues the timing and
results of my tests established
circumstances of Unknowing supplement
contamination not the use of
performance-enhancing substances it
sounds like he's saying someone messaged
mislabeled it are they saying he's
somebody maybe mislabeled something that
he takes circumstances of a knowing
supplement contamination someone put in
substances or something that he didn't
know about are we believing it no I
can't believe anybody any more I give up
I give up
damn it's unreal immediately the
Internet's like you were taking
performance-enhancing drugs and you play
like that well I mean he'd never played
as bad as everybody wants to just jump
all over him of course and he's pretty
put together if you saw him in person oh
he's a pretty jack he's got muscles for
sure yes and yeah I mean again it's just
like Thomas Davis there's two guys that
have you made me bet that they took I
would probably say no but it's hard for
me to take them at their word it's hard
for me to just to go because you know
and been around enough football players
to know what they're kind of obsessed
with everything they put in their body
for the most part
they're anything where let's say the NFL
is about to put new stuff on their
contamination list is there anything
that I could take pictures of what I
have and send it to the NFL and go I've
been taking this is this going to clear
yes oh there is yes you can send it to
the NFL PA and they're gonna tell you
they're gonna give you actual the things
you can buy off the shelf at GNC that
you can actually buy and they're gonna
have a whole nother list let's go don't
buy these ones they have illegal
substances that you'll test positive for
it even though they might not be a
steroid or whatever let me just say this
note to all NFL players there's no magic
pill okay stop with the stupid GNC crap
workout eat healthy take a damn protein
shake call it a day
I mean gosh oh if I take the GNC pill I
might I might get four inches on my
vertical and some other body part might
get four more inches wink wink if you
know what I mean biceps biceps right
that's what I was thinking not but
regardless stop like give it up there's
no special pill
I know these are amazing athletes Jenna
get over it you don't need creatine
before your workout oh I bench 295
instead of 290 cuz a creatine whoa
that's amazing
big offseason like just freaking workout
yeah watch what you eat or eat more of
it take a protein shake start it all
over again the next day
do you this always turns into a
conversation about competition and
needing to be the best and fueling and
all that stuff but I also know that you
guys are inherently repetitive yes and
you always will do the same thing all
the time so the introduction of these
new supplements and stuff I feel like
you guys though are so routine that it
would seem you know counter to what you
guys normally I know but I think like
how you started in an office what the
real thing is they go oh we can get a
little edge right here yeah I've got an
edge I'm both gonna go around the corner
this often to tackle now that I took
this gnz supplement my thing is is I'm
waiting for the person that gets busted
to out the person that gives them the
supplements don't tell me that your
supplements got weird
tell me I have an issue this trainer
Mark Murphy changed my supplements
that's like like if it's not you then
give me who it was but I think it's them
more times than not that's the problem
this is the NFL - this is not the NBA or
baseball where everybody's got private
trainers some do only the big-time stars
yeah I want to see like a guy on YouTube
being like here is what I take all the
time I'm gonna give you all of it like
these guys put out their statements
they're apologetic videos I want someone
showing me all the supplements they take
and somehow this worked and now it's not
like I just know that if I was accused
of something I would be going on a world
tour I would be showing my paper I would
be showing my paper bag listen this is
what I tested positive for I don't take
this whatever it is I mean I think also
as a society the apalla the tearful
apology or the tearful denial carries no
weight yeah it's done I've seen it in
politics I've seen it all the time a lot
right I always say this who was the Andy
Pettitte I took steroids and everybody
went okay cool I'm probably the vote
from the Hall of Fame because he's on
right but all these other people I know
I'm done I know all right the last one
400 big offs we had offseason was Dez
Bryant cut from the Cowboys released I
had a list of teams though it's not
funny all right so Dez Bryant released
from the Cowboys I'm not shocked by this
he was getting paid a lot of money he
was not at that level anymore it makes
sense even though the Cowboys are really
shallow at wide receiver and for an
owner who claims to have all the money
in the world man does he release people
and give out bad contracts it's
unbelievable he does Dez Bryant yes
where in your heart of hearts do you
think he ends up I so I know we have a
social video coming out my heart of
hearts I think he's gonna end up in
Baltimore meets a raven
I mean he just seems that way he's
perfect for a Joe Flacco Joe Flacco's
great at throwing the receivers who
can't separate I mean I'm not trying to
say that as a knock I mean that is truly
is like a big like Crabtree right where
you can go oh you're not covered you
mean you're covered you're not open well
I'll just throw a back shoulder ball and
you guys have such phenomenal hands
you'll just snag it so I could see that
he fits within the attitude of the
football team he does every
right he's not afraid to run block and
be physical that way we talk about his
limitations yeah but he's still a good
why does she's good he's a good number
two I just don't think he's in number
one I had three teams yeah I also had
the bills in there I had the Panthers in
there because I think Cam Newton could
not go that sales pitch but the three
that I came out with Ravens yeah just
because I everything you said yeah
Raiders okay just because I look at
their team and go okay so it's Jordi and
Cooper and maybe I don't know his
relationship with Gruden but I thought
he could fit in there and the other team
and where I'm gonna make my prediction
right
but again des is picking this is not
this is free agency I think the best fit
for him is the Bengals I think when you
look at the Bengals he I think would be
a great complement to AJ Green yeah cuz
AJ's taking the top off yeah Brandon
LaFell is their number two yeah I'm not
putting any stock in John Ross right our
Boyd right now but I think in Cincinnati
with Marvin Lewis and the team and their
identity and and the players they've had
before but also the the pairing with AJ
Green yeah I thought that would be a
very good it's a good spot I never
thought about that one that it really is
and of course there are the the type of
team that certainly can handle those
type of personalities I mean I'm not
gonna put that out there it's not crazy
now the thing that I think people like
them might think are crazy is like he's
not that much better than Brandon LaFell
see this is where the people got to fall
into this like des Brian is a projection
at this point that's from truly what he
is because you can't say we're gonna
line Dez Bryant outside and let him win
one-on-one Oh game on No so what you
have to do is say damn can Dez Bryan's
start playing in the slot a little bit
because that's what he's gonna have to
do I like a Brandon Marshall when I get
to that point and we haven't really seen
it goes up better than Brandon LaFell he
like does up he does that he does do
that but I don't know if he's a better
route runner and things like that either
so he's yes he's a better physical
specimen he's definitely gonna catch the
50/50 balls I don't think it's
significantly better I think it's gonna
be very interesting to see to me who
offers him what because because the
Ravens need to mess around with their
salary cap yeah for them right now the
bengals have the cash that's why i made
on my pick because they
like 21 million in the south my other
two teams I went with in the social
piece or whatever was I went Green Bay
number two okay they could go him and
Davante Adams Dez Bryant or Green Bay
right and Rogers is like Flacco where if
you're covered it doesn't really matter
he the team that the the catch happened
again right would be pretty humble it
would be and then the Cardinals that was
my third team that was the other team I
thought about because there don't have a
lot of talent at the receiver visit is
Fitzgerald who of course is coming to an
end JJ Nelson yes you want to give maybe
Sam Bradford one more weapon the only
team in the NFC East that would need Dez
Bryant is the Cowboys and no one else is
good agreed I know everybody was saying
all that I have a hard time the other
only other team I could look at and go
maybe is the Redskins right because
maybe they're not sold on a Josh Dotson
or whatever it may be but they also just
signed Paul Richardson yes and I mean
Paul Richardson's fat that's 110 million
a year yeah they're dead Ryan's not
gonna get 10 million a year I really
don't think no I think he's gonna get in
the eight states right eight and a half
somewhere in there I would agree again
the biggest thing is he has lost the
ability to scare people with the nine
route or the go route right and you know
and we talk about it all the time if you
once you lose that as an outside
receiver it's really hard to get open on
an out route or a comeback or a 12-yard
curl route because the really top-notch
DB's just go well damn he can't run by
me I'm just gonna sit on all this
underneath stuff all right so let's go
then to show me the money because these
will be polite you deliver took out all
three these will be players that will
get money or have got money what's the
first one adidas wants Kaepernick adidas
wants Kaepernick Seahawks signed Stephen
Morris Austin Davis okay so this is one
of my favorite stories that apparently
no one's really paying attention you
know what nobody else paid attention to
that I'd like to just point out real
quick that the Jacksonville Jaguars
traded for the 71st first best
quarterback in football we talked about
this literally two weeks ago we talked
about they have the 71st that gets
hilarious I don't even know you sure we
talked about this I literally have
comments that said when you guys talked
about Kody Kessler to the Jaguars me and
my friends lost our minds I'm losing my
mind go ahead I'm keeping this thing
together with glue sticks and tape why
do you coughing in one more time
for us black lung I'm dying okay okay by
the way with Dez Bryant yes Allen Hurns
came out and said that they might as
well retire 88 I went well Drew Pearson
wore 88 and I went and Michael Irvin
right and I went and compared the number
of student Dez Bryant and Drew Pearson
who do you think was better Drew Pearson
or Dez Bryant you tie stierson played 43
more games Dez Bryan had 42 more catches
in 43 less games right he only had 363
less yards and 43 less games he averaged
15 point 9 more yards per game he had 25
more touchdowns than Drew Pearson in 43
less games but you know sure Drew
Pearson was a three-time All Pro on a
Super Bowl champion there's a different
game it's a different Gary Hardin and
then I look at their height and weight
right and Dez was 62 225 and Drew
Pearson was 6 foot 1 84 it's just a
different human yes to compare them it's
not even close yes but Michael Irvin's
the number one he's the number one ad
not even yes yes but they should retire
that number I don't know why they keep
giving it out I don't know either they
don't do that they just like and they
just enter names into the Ring of Honor
they don't retire numbers in Dallas man
because nobody gets retired nobody
all right so show me the money adidas
wants Kaepernick this is my favorite
story of the weekend they go out there
and they sign Stephen Morris and they
Reese I know Stan Davis his backup
quarterbacks after they were gonna plan
to have Kaepernick come up but they said
what is your plan if you're going to
keep kneeling what are you gonna do and
he didn't have one apparently this is
whatever reportedly and they cancelled
the meeting
well adidas has come out mark King the
president of Adidas North America and
said we want to endorse Kaepernick when
he gets signed quote we love athletes
that have a platform to make the world a
better place if they're an activist in a
way that brings attention to something
that moves the world forward even if
there's controversy at that moment we're
really interested in those athletes
because I think it represents the world
today he added adidas isn't in the
business of activism but quote allowing
our athletes to tell their story is
really important to us
number one amazing move
yes amazing move to all the athletes
that you're trying to represent that's
what the shoe industry has become it's
become a player representative industry
I saw we were in LA adidas they have
hard and they have you know all the top
guys
they represent DJ's they represent
musicians Kanye's they are about talent
acquisition there are their best
athletes actually sordin Rogers Rogers
is adidas cleats we're here now yes
Aaron judge you think you think so
there's a number of them but what I
thought think is so interesting when we
want somebody off of television we say
get rid of the sponsors you know
challenge the sponsors when we talk
about a player entering the NFL
controversy you know we don't want the
sponsors to get upset but now we have a
sponsor who's saying they want to
endorse if this player ever against the
chance and the reason I love it is it
takes away one of those pegs in the
argument against Kaepernick does he
still have it at quarterback
that's one knock that we always have
he's a system guy he doesn't fit our
team we hear that all the time we're
worried about our fans and our club box
it's in our premium whatever and what is
gonna happen with sponsorships and stuff
when one sponsorship is willing to go
out on a limb and say we want to support
this guy it's and it's it's a great
brand adidas is one of the highest
rising brands in the world today it just
gives other sponsors confidence as well
it's it's it's just it's a vote of
confidence for a player yeah and I
wasn't expecting this to happen
but I think that's enormous in just the
overall sphere of confidence and I do I
said it two years ago now a year and a
half the Seahawks are the team that can
do it with Kaepernick and I'm just I'm
getting the feeling that you know where
adidas is located just like all the
other shoe companies Pacific Northwest I
just still think that Kaepernick is
gonna end up on the Seahawks before the
year ends before the year starts yeah
you're not feeling too Gotha I love that
adidas did that certainly I mean it's a
great move I mean of course then they
probably see some monetary gain I'm
trying to do that but and they're gonna
see some monetary loss too I'm sure I'm
sure
but it ain't happen he's not going he's
not going anywhere
he's not getting signed I just don't I
know it's all the all these calls these
workouts men ain't gonna happen
they're all BS you think so yeah they're
scared they're too scared they're scared
of alienating a certain part of their
fan base that's gonna feel very offended
by it man yeah I know it's a shame it's
a it's ridiculous
if there's one team that needs a true
insurance policy for a quarterback that
puts him out there that could get hurt
it is the Seahawks is it really right
they are a 1 in 15 - it doesn't matter
he could be a great backup for anybody
on any team it doesn't matter he's got
high-level talent I mean high level
talent like he is a gifted runner and
he's got an incredibly strong arm and he
was really never in a great offense I
mean never I mean that's that I think
that people forget like those 49er teams
were good because they were physically
good but they did nothing on offense it
was basic it was you know we're gonna
smash it in your face with gore or you
better be careful because we might not
give it to Gore and Kaepernick might run
around the side for 80 and then if you
get too many people at the line of
scrimmage he's gonna throw her over the
top of your head for 80 I mean the
offense was really based around his
unbelievable skill set so it's a shame
that he's not in the NFL
then his make-or-break year was with Jim
Tomsula yeah like we look at that now
and laugh but his career is défi like
with the ability to come back as defined
by the Jim Tomsula year I know which
wasn't bad either
there's a lot of good so he touchdowns
for interceptions it's it's it's just
not gonna happen
I mean listen I can we get our agreed on
a team first let's go him first and then
go to Kaepernick you're right
because Kaepernick of course is you know
there's a lot more Club number one
villain all right so last two for show
me the money
Browns Jarvis Landry big contract five
years yes
seventy five point five million right
forty-seven guaranteed 47 guaranteed
puts him behind Mike Evans DeAndre
Hopkins and tied with Julio Jones he's
tied with AJ Green for fifth in annual
average at 15 million a year Giulio
Jones is eighth meanwhile the combined
2018 cap of the Patriots 7 highest-paid
wide receivers is 16.8 million yeah
Jarvis Landry yeah does this make you
question John Dorsey at all giving in
this kind of contract I mean yes of
course that's mean I was this to me I
was like Jarvis Landry congratulations
good for Jarvis holy crap I've had a man
right he has no business being in the
conversation with these guys that are
he's in the AJ Green you know again
listen Sammy Watkins is up there I don't
think he really deserves to be quite
there yet either with the Mike Evans
DeAndre Hopkins and our Antonio Brown I
can understand the same he walk-ins
thing a little bit more than the Jarvis
Landry I think what they're doing with
Cleveland is they're paying him more for
attitude and culture - I think that's
the other thing you have to take into
account why was his attitude and culture
bad in Miami I just because I think he
was wanting to get paid like this and
they were like come on man I mean your
attitude and culture is not worth that
here right so Cleveland they're in a
different spot they're a different team
they're trying to kind of build
something and appoint leaders and this
is listen one of our highest-paid guys a
worker you do special teams a blocking
the run game you know all those things I
think that's what he is he's more of a
model citizen for so right now for the
next month
yeah the face of the franchise is Jarvis
Landry kind of yeah and then whatever
quarterback they draft right it will
transition to him right I mean they got
they mean the culture worth that much
probably not not quite that much but
they made a trade for them and they got
to make moves and okay and you know what
I also think about like this knowing
you're gonna draft a quarterback yeah
knowing that you're gonna have the
rookie pay scale for your quarterback
for the next five years right
could take some of that money and
allocated he's healthy he's dependable
you've got a guy like Josh Gordon and
Corey Coleman who we don't know ever
what's gonna be there
that's the I think that's like that's
what I mean I think it sort of plays
into all of it like you're not just for
the team but for that position you're
here every day let me tell you this
right if Jarvis Landry can make Josh
Gordon play consistently yeah and hold
him accountable right then I would have
paid him a hundred million dollars right
because now you're getting to yeah you
know the kids they're gonna keep getting
Josh Gordon at these cheap contracts so
maybe that's it - maybe Jarvis Landry is
kind of getting some of Josh Gordon's
money well I just think he's all of that
you're right I mean he's the insurance
policy is the leader he's the guy that
they just know they're gonna be able to
depend on on a week-to-week basis plus
they have an offensive coordinator and
Todd Haley who knows how to get those
kind of guys open so they feel like I'm
sure they feel like you know even though
we might have concerns about him getting
open against the league corners argh
argh I are off it's coordinators gonna
put them as positions to succeed that
will then justify the contract last guy
that was show me the money a little
under the radar yeah
Cameron Meredith whoo Bears put like a
second-round tender on him right try to
get cute not give him a lot of money
right
saves picked him up yeah well they give
a million a year I think right and now
he's in New Orleans
Cameron Meredith was a stud when he
played he was and I'm curious how a team
like Chicago could mess around and let
him go a team that has big wide receiver
issues because Allen Robinson's coming
off an ACL Kevin White's coming off
whatever Kevin White's doing your best
receiver last year was a running back
and now Karimun Meredith on the Saints I
think is is a really dynamic option that
they just got out of know a very dynamic
option a guy that can do a lot of
different things for their offense - I
mean Cameron Meredith he can win on the
outside and he could be the slot guy
over the middle - he's a little bit of a
versatile guy that has no weakness he
might not have any real legitimate great
elite miss in my mouth weeks ever what
Brandon Coleman yeah he's gonna be or
even maybe like a Willie sneeze a
Michael Thomas camera Meredith Willie
Snead in the Sun right slot maybe bring
in a snot
that's in your notes knots in your
Brandon Coleman I think is he just had
some fumbles last year he has never
really reached his potential he's a big
real big guy and just a little clunky
that way but I just put this in here
because I thought you know what we're
gonna look back at this in the middle of
the year and be like how did the Bears
let him go yeah well I mean the Bears I
think y'all so you got it they paid of
course Allen Robinson right and they
paid your tight end tray burden a good
amount of money too yes so I think
probably was the designation that led to
this no I know I know well they ought to
put a first-round designation on yeah I
am well they were trying to cut corners
and they were hoping nothing happened
and then of course they have Kevin white
too so this is not a huge blow to their
football but that was my point is that
you're gonna rely on Kevin white and
Alan Robinson both coming off big
injuries again like I just that's not
that safe to me I know what camera
Maryland's coming off an injury to so
yeah but III know I hear you he's got
great potential in that offense he
certainly can do some big things Saints
are gonna be so good should be all right
what else you got for me before we wrap
up Tomic ensue got 93 from the Rams
Ethan Westbrook gave it to him oh did he
yes he did and that's all I know that's
it I don't think I have anything else
I've been watching draft I mean I don't
know what else do you want to talk about
but not today okay what aren't so you I
know you're watching a little bit of the
defensive line is exciting you it is yes
D lines is exciting I mean it the
interior D lineman so far I am excited
about that's awesome yeah there's a lot
of good players so Wednesday we're gonna
have Peter King you know next week
Monday it sounds like there's a lot of
things that could happen next week so I
don't want to preview it yeah but I know
that Miller is coming to town on Tuesday
next week's freaking draft yeah so we're
gonna have I think Miller on the show
Wednesday and do like a big round table
discussion cool to lead up into our
draft coverage by Thursday night it's
gonna be on Facebook on the bleacher
report page we're gonna be live I talked
with a bunch of people about whether or
not it's gonna be the app and how that's
gonna work but I do know this we are
going to put maybe like pics one through
10 as a YouTube video 11 through 20 as a
YouTube video we're gonna do it well
this is what we're gonna do
yeah we're gonna clip it out and it's
gonna be on youtube if you want to watch
it later but if you want to watch it
live with us on draft night watch on
Facebook and I think it's gonna be a lot
of fun you got something else well I
think you can announce our Monday guests
is it official that's what it said 230
to 250 on Monday all right we are gonna
be having sand Arnold next Monday which
is going to be fun and Sam Donald's mom
so sims was gonna tell how he feels
about Sam Darnell and how he's gonna
flame out write to his mom no I don't
think he's gonna flame that I just don't
see the number one or number two Peck
and I know you're gonna call me out on
all this in front of him but we'll have
a good conversation I'll tell him I'm
just so excited to see his chin in
person hey listen he's it's real I saw
it in person it's real it's a good one
it's like a Johnny Bryan I mean his I
can't wait to ask him about his
grandfather who was like the original
marble man his nose dick hammer dick
hammer of course I mean one of the
greatest names in the history of names
yes he was the Marlboro Man yes it's
amazing see this is why I think the
turtles getting like them okay so we're
gonna Peter King on Wednesday Darnell on
Monday and then a beautiful round table
on Wednesday for Sims peace out homies
vendrick Oh
congratulation gage I'm letting it out
of the Hat I don't give a damn you know
and now uh pressures on me all right and
the lef koe man we will holler at you
later we will see you guys Wednesday
evening love you very much talk to you
soon Henry